This is side B.
At Station six the tape continues in a few seconds
and divide into for cation he was talking about the poverty of Bombay. You see my mother's father came from India.
But he came from Darjeeling which was further in than in the north.
That's the most something about there in Bombay in spite of this extreme poverty and. Distress. I was very distressed.
I still felt you know were. That I belonged there. It was quite extraordinary. What can you say a bit more about.
Was the time when I was very young I was twenty twenty one.
And let my hair grow not bandit and people often thought that I was.
Some thought a bad mother of a family that we never treasured it as we did our fathers for some bloody reason. But.
I think we should have had to it's hard to describe the feeling I had when I was.
I just thought it was my land to let alone. Well we had food there and the welcome was overwhelming.
And I was very impressed with the trade you. You know who were with us. I would think long till I got Paddy.
Some more prominent Labor party members in fact
and I was greatly moved by their tremendous understanding of the situation there. Plus the compassion. And.
I found the members of the trade union in that delegation. Gave us great worth. This beautiful spirit.
Beautiful People and well things I must do is make contact with them.
There is one of the members of the trade union wrote to me recently.
He's in Western Australia I'll look him up when I go. Anyhow.
So we have had to get on with it back to the went up through work force the Suez Canal.
It's port Port I hadn't missed it. Thanks. And we went ashore there. Went ashore at the other end.
Anyhow it's sufficient that I say that because when I'm probably if ever I write the book I will check it out.
If I want it now we're going through the Suez. I thought that was beautiful. I thought it was lovely.
I thought it was just beautiful. And coming out in the morning and seeing really the banks with the date tree.
This is so different somehow. And I have to remember to describe that in considerable detail. Because I left it.
Just left. And we came out of it. And then the boat move rapidly. And we're on to you.
I just want to say that as we were crossing the ocean from.
To Naples one of delegates were sitting on the rail of the Packers a ship where many of the Main St
and he was lost into the sea. Was lost. It was very sad terrible the boat. Searched for the body. Couldn't be found.
So we went out and early one morning in the distance. Christophe was marked for serious.
And I will always see the knife and and cruelly. I thought I don't want to see anything after.
I just want to say that when I went back to Naples about a spray of Atlanta ten years ago with windy.
You couldn't see anything so polluted so polluted but the by so beautiful. We were.
And then we were told to leave ship there. And we would go by but we would just in our hotel.
Then we would go back past. Up to Rome. Everyone thought this was great and I will never forget.
Margaret Margaret Walker The costumes were not all finished when we had to get on the ship in Sydney.
So learn be how old. Margaret Payne Margaret just said to John look I'll have to take the sewing machine.
And the materials and so we had great sewing. And got the costumes.
But I always remember sitting in the bus waiting for the last person to leave the boat
and who should have been a moment when Margaret when John Kerry in the Singer sewing machine.
So we got into the past and we were taken to our hotel. Now.
Naples to me was just a city I felt where I could live and I could and I. And the warmth of the people.
Just is so wonderful and I went out into the street. And felt so. I didn't feel strange at that time.
It really was an exceptionally poor country. It was living on the Marshall Plan.
Taking this pic eighty out of that came from the United States. And things were awfully.
And one of the things that I had I found in one of the streets
and I thought it was a little shop that sold Italian blouses and cardigans and pullovers
and they were pure pullovers and cardigans So what do I do. I mean usually by a yellow pullover and cardigan.
I had taken money to do this kind of thing because I had a friend who'd been there. And had bought her.
Thank you so I thought out take the money and. And I did.
And what I would go into the shops the telly and women would come
and look in my face because they'd never seen a black face before.
And they would touch my cheek and they all laugh and I put their arms around me. Just.
And then to go and see the ruins of Pompei. And I pinched off and I thought. Am I really frightened.
Am I this person who came from Mobile umbrella. Or promote no.
Never in Hawaii streams into thinking he would leave the shores of Australia.
And here are you walking through the ruins of pump. And pump I said many things to me.
And it told me yourself the great culture that must surely have been there. That was buried.
And I sat there and looked at that wonderful mount in the distance blue and deep blue. And they probably.
Just one of my. Italy did great things. So after quite some time some young. Million. Italian men.
Came and said that they would now be in charge of us they were working for peace.
And they would have screwed us in the past up to. And you know.
I was full of never a question when you just went it was a different situation in the world.
And there was tremendous trust with this and I too much people just wanted to leave. The bus a big beautiful big story.
And we were housed in pinch you're all about it you know. And there were very rich.
Romans who were involved in the work for peace to abolish.
And to make sure that the fastest were thrown out of the country and. They would talk about the war to the Australians.
And tell the Australians what it was like when the now two jack boots walked the beautiful streets over.
And they talked about Italian fastest. Who joined up with German Nazis and murdered their. And it was different.
I mean you read about things but when it comes as it were from the horse's mouth.
It's well it said to me to look there you dropped. You have to put every atom of energy. Into working to eliminate war.
That's what it said to me and said it was to be with these young people and they were all the people.
Who went into the streets and would say to me. This is where my brother were shot. This is where my father were shot.
By the Germans by the Italian. And I went to St Pete. And are so well in the attic.
Worth billions and billions of dollars
and the problems of the Italian people could have been solved overnight if they'd sell some of their junk
and I walked to the very pinnacle of the tumor saying to go. The dome of St Peter's.
And the steps were so worn it was like putting my feet into holes of concrete and I would look at some of the day
and I thought well things I did when I could when I had the strength.
And there was one request and we were there in the summer. That we should.
Cover our heads with a scarf and the main couldn't wear shorts. And that was OK. No but it was respect.
So I spent a few days coming and going to the Vatican. I knew that they hadn't raised and.
To help the Jews in any way I looked at the world.
Literally and had told us that the Vatican could have done much to keep the Nazis out of Italy and I didn't.
So then I said after we had a great and they are mean we saw a lot. And being. Going along the happy and worry.
Well I think when I said child at Sunday school. I was told about a peer peer and where was that poor all over.
Whoever it was who went along. And here are poor. It was.
And I don't know if other people felt the why I did
but I felt so fortunate that I could actually walk there put my feet down on the way
and then finally they said well now we're going to do you know.
So we're hoping the passes again you know I mean the bloody fast these narrow roads man with one hand on the horn one
on the steering wheel. You know but finally we got to. In general at that time had a communist Council.
And they worked very very closely with the Christians and with the Social Democrats
and they were all into tech looked after us. But you see. The Cold War I would say was almost at its peak. And.
The police were watching us because they knew we were going into East Berlin. Now at that time.
Many had already made it illegal. For Australians to travel into the Eastern Bloc and the name as well.
So we carried a passport.
That said our passport was not valid for the Eastern Bloc
and listed all the countries Czechoslovakia Hungary remaining the Soviet Union. And then also China and Vietnam.
So I could say that because it just reminds me that it wasn't an easy thing to be traveling into the Eastern Bloc
and we. Into East Berlin. In. You know how we were taken over the great doc. Yeah it's great.
Doc works around the trade unionists and. Then one day he apparently told the leaders of application. Look we tell you.
Just movement is still active and many are in the police force. We have to get you out of the you know.
Where you will just take you so once again we got into buses and we waited outside.
What the narrow country roads which were plastered with slogans and Logan's would read what's the word for word
and the French word any. Bread and. All along the narrow roads. So not much wider than.
The all stars were covered with this white. People who were hosting you could.
Suspect that you were under threat that there was some real danger. Most certainly. And so we got in the past.
We drove past and finally the bus stop and we had to take I'm lucky day.
And I said Now I will help you all to get to the top of this mountain. And it was called Mt Kaga later.
And nothing could go up there except a flying fox you know Fox.
And so they sent our stuff up by flying fox and that was my first trip.
And many trips that I made since then I never took more than one suitcase and my handbag.
A little pack for the plane you know but that was it.
It always has been that way ever since and I was so grateful that I just had this one bag.
And then we had to climb this mountain. So ninety one.
But they humor kept us going through all of all people who are young and strong. In finding we got the top.
And they were whole lot of teams. And.
And then he told us that over a very simple me you know off soup with a little bone in it. Beef and the soup head spin.
Each not very much. And pester. And rolls and I baked the rolls some more and brought them here.
Very little food in Italy very little and they told us that that was the case for the telly and party movement.
That I had used it and. At night. The young. Partisans who were. Would talk to us about being patters in the war.
Against mostly me and Hitler. And the leader. There was a man by the name of Frank a young man. And he said.
How are his father was also in the Patterson movement and the fastest quote a group of party. Partisans dig a trench.
And they instilled them all up and shot them. And his father feigned. Survived.
And he was there in the came looking after the water supply and what have you.
There was very little food and bad luck in my tale
and there were the people from the Latin American countries so they'd sing or dance and sing.
When they'd met but it was a great opportunity for rehearsing and dances and so on.
And that was carried out every night. Then one day.
One of the leaders of the tell you new movement came up and said well the police now know you're here.
And we have to get you out.
And the most important group was a man who could dance group because they were organized they had something to present
a struggle. And it was said they would get the highest priority. So together with my fellow dances.
We were taken down from the mountain. And a little brass came and picked us up and took us to Milan.
And in Milan we were put on trial. And when a sentence you Rick. Asked my question. I just.
We got out of the train greeted nans who took us to what have they pinch.
I could not fully what was put on the breakfast table across someone's piles of jam and butter and cream
and the milk would come in large jugs coffee. You could drink gallons of it if you wanted to Switzerland.
So we stayed in Zurich for quite a while and I thought it was beautiful. Of everything in the street.
And someone came and said Well it's time now.
We want to be there for the opening we'll be held up in Austria for a long time. But we'll go up to Austria now.
And they were very worried about sending the dance group by train because in into broke.
There were the Russian soldiers but also the American soldiers
and the Americans were there to make sure nobody crossed the border in fact because in Austria was under four powers.
And. It was very dicey extremely dicey. But I was with the group so they said no we're going to send you home by plane.
And we were sent in an old French plane that rattled and I only prayed that it would get over the Great.
Graft Lochner with her safely because the snow was.
And all of you know snow covered mountains here and we got over and he landed in Vienna and they were made. Austrians.
And I had a small army too of peace because they had to intervene and they knew about
and those who resisted the Nazis were reorganizing again those who were murdered are might. And so they took us on.
And they said look just for a night we have to put you in rather uncomfortable but fortunately.
We'll put you in a school which we still have.
And the school was next to our market the market had been bombed out and part of the school had been bombed.
But we were housed in the school and then they'd take us into the market for breakfast
and they would be just lovely hot milk coffee and. And Abaddon. And after a couple of days they say.
We have to hide you look in and they took us to a place outside of the. Well I called Spark.
And there was nothing but a stream of water. And some very primitive little tidbits that we were to sleep in.
We left the bulk of that was being cared for in the school which just took a raft close
but we were up there for a whole fortnight actually sleeping under the stars and.
And I'll tell you who was they had to break. A lot. And he was hiding. He was afraid. He was also there.
And he observed. What have you. And. And so. Maybe we just had family. Didn't know how to live.
And there was a local pub to have a road on the edge of the Danube and it was owned by a woman.
And pubs in the country they were pretty rough believe you me but we'd go down there and we buy our lunch there.
And it was very.
You know she would make these huge blocks of bread there but more like a damp than a bread
and you could have a bowel of beef soup.
And you sat at these long tables but there was plenty off and she used to put barley and rice in.
And so we we had more food there than we had over in Italy and these great big miners and what he's needed.
And she used to make the most wonderful cakes. So she would do the cakes down in the basement.
And down in the basement she kept all her very precious.
Like yours to use to look yours to flavor the cakes and one night we were there and she invited us down.
That was raping the Aboriginal prison travelling with us and myself
and Ray by then had become very poorly with daughter. I'm sure he'd taken the daughter after he came out.
So the daughter said Come Dance days when Mum's cake. And by this time.
Ray and I have got a favorite German we know what cake is if we did and much else
and I had done a fair bit of German before I left with Paul. So we were able to communicate with this woman and.
Daughter and we sat at a great big table downstairs and they gave us a little bit of apricot le Cure and a cake.
Each and then the mother fell asleep she was exhausted and her and Ray set there and I ate eggs. So I said to write a.
You should lay some money and eat it.
Of course but things like this were happening there was no such thing as a shower. So you use the stream which ran.
Which the camp was around and you'd go there to the stream
but you'd have to make sure that you were like at the very top of the stream.
Because if you're down on the bottom you could reach shore sake someone would be at the top looking down arm.
So we bathed in the strain and we washed in the stream.
And I had to pinch myself to believe that I was going on to the city of Berlin
and here I am off in a stream in Austria and washing my clothes that are going to the local pub to you or so.
The local policeman. Became extremely helpful.
And it was interesting you know I've had a gutful of the nutsy these people who were full
and he couldn't get on his bike and go and ring up for the organizers and it was just lovely. Then one day he.
The leader of one of the youth came and said You have to get an extra tomorrow.
To battle in so we packed up with back to the school. But that day turned into three or four days.
And I was able to see more of it here and there and to experience.
Coffee in a coffee shop and it was as I had read about it and you could see it would interrupt.
The atmosphere with many of course. But there was the man who smoked his cigar in a pipe.
Who ended and I could walk the streets and I bought it in there and.
To go with my golden pullovers from Italy and I was so pleased because it's took me. Well in London.
And I went and looked at the Opera House which had not been restored and the badly. I felt quite at peace there.
Go out at night and we'd see the British marching in the streets. The Americans all the soldiers who'd. The Russians.
And finally they said well it's time to get the train. So we all packed off to the west Bahnhof I'll stop.